who is going to surprise us the most
this season me of course oh my god hello
me duh I know it sounds like I'm talking
about myself a lot vote Hale why not
hey a little ego is good right
especially when we're talking about
RuPaul's Drag Race is a biggest season
yet are you ready for this wild ride
that is drag race oh yes I've been
waiting for a long time and she's an
11-3 edge everything that you know about
drag race everything that you thought
you knew about drag race throw it out
the window because all of the rules have
changed
it's just gonna be absolutely friggin
bonkers that's about it so I gotta say
about it to me bonkers
it's like drag race on speed if you're
not ready for it I mean right let me
look at the tuck is tighter the wigs are
more snatched we're ready for it et
gathered the whole cast to learn some
season 11 secrets because a 900 the look
that drama there's just a lot of things
on the season that have not happened on
drag race before so that's gonna be
insanity they're bringing so much to the
table like so much drama so much look
these girls for looks look at the looks
after look at the look mic drop [ __ ] we
got some talented [ __ ] on a budget in
this season honey that's the difference
artist oh and untuck you guys make sure
you watch untuck untuck is definitely
going to be very surprised things trying
to figure out how 15 girls are gonna
make it all the way through in figuring
out who's gonna make it all you know
we're used to seeing like 12 13 but 15
yeah
Nedim brought this [ __ ] back now wait a
minute
we're gonna get enough last season hey
girl what's T I don't want to give
nothing away but love i'ma tell you this
you know season 10 they got to meet miss
Gangi season 11 I'm gonna introduce
everyone to Vanessa van Jin the tail
don't get it twisted we all know if ing
right and she's made a huge impact on
not very little time so she's obviously
big competition earnest are second
chances are not giving often so fir
RuPaul and everyone to say come bring
her back in you know she left too soon
or whatever the case may be it's a
blessed shooting knows the game a little
bit I thought that you know she's gonna
be the biggest competition yeah maybe
ask her how this thing works
hello what knocking else already that
you welfare you can be like what did you
do in there okay well I know to keep a
shape
don't hide booting up it's and of course
that all I was thinking about is my
stuff like [ __ ] you better not go home
you know RuPaul coming hello hello hello
and I'm like I don't want to go we've
got like a lot of socially active Queens
we've got Queens who are Instagram super
famous we've just got like the best
diversity I think the show has ever seen
it's the first season where we have
seven ethnic girls in one season so it's
gonna be a lot of personality a lot of
flavor well first of all when I saw
plastic and I was like what is she doing
here
why is she even here
[Music]
[Applause]
that she's fishy is healed so I was like
okay wait a minute now we need the
autopsy port or some I mean uh um on DNA
tenth or something I think that's the
one man she's so beautiful so I was like
oh I was like when I first saw Brooklyn
I was like up for my miss continent oh
here we go
oh my god it's really a serious
competition baby
I immediately clock the pageant girls of
Karia in Brooklyn I was like oh they
Paris house and I competed against them
what different divisions I'm trying to
get the titles they got and so I was
just like wait here like I can't beat
them in real life honey but I can beat
you a real wild drag race there's so
many legendary people that are could
have come out that a lot of people don't
know about but at the answer the season
I think everyone's gonna like talk about
that and they're gonna like you know
blow up at the end of the day it is a
competition we all are here for the win
don't think I'm just here to be part of
RuPaul's best friend race eat or be
eaten
it's a lot of cloth coming out it's a
lot of tux slipping it's a lot of baby
it's some stuff going on I don't ever
get in fights what do you mean a drag
queen right now so nice hahaha there's
one crown sometimes two maybe the crown
me and me again and me again they crown
both Miss Vangie and Vanessa exactly
that part
[Music]